[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Norbert König ist auch dabei
für den Sport sehr gern guten Abend und
das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
Söders Ultimatum in der flugblattaffäre
Macht Bayerns Ministerpräsident Druck
und verlangt von seinem Vize Aiwanger
möglichst noch heute Antworten
lernen mit Luftalarm in der Ukraine
beginnt das neue Schuljahr für die
Kleinsten soll es trotz Ausnahmezustand
ein Feiertag sein
und viertes Spiel 4 Sieg bei der
Basketball-WM gewinnt das deutsche Team
auch gegen Georgien und steht im
Viertelfinale
[Musik]
was wird aus Hubert Aiwanger hält
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Söder an
seinem Vize Fest noch heute fordert
Söder Antworten zur Affäre um ein
antisemitisches Flugblatt heftige Kritik
am Chef der Freien Wähler kommt vom
antisemitismusbeauftragten der
Bundesregierung klein
eiwangers bisheriges Vorgehen sich als
Opfer einer Kampagne zu stilisieren und
sich möglichst spät möglichst wenig und
möglichst empathielos zu äußern Diener
als schlechtes Vorbild simonset
als Markus Söder heute die karpfensaison
eröffnet wartet er immer noch auf
Antworten 25 Fragen hat er seinem
vize-hubert Aiwanger gestellt seitdem
sind drei Tage vergangen das Warten
überschattet auch so das Wahlkampf der
eigentlich Bilder eines zupackenden
Ministerpräsidenten produzieren soll für
mich ist wichtig dass die 25 Fragen
jetzt umfassen und glaubwürdig
beantwortet werden und zwar zeitnah und
zeitnah heißt am besten noch heute
während Söder wartet genießt Aiwanger
das Bad in der Menge Bierzelt Auftritt
in Niederbayern
viel Unterstützung an seiner Basis vor
seinem Anhängern schaltet Aiwanger heute
auch Attacke und wittert eine
Verschwörung
hier wurde
von
Wähler zu schwächen eventuell sogar die
Grünen in die Landesregierung zu bringen
das ist nicht unser Ziel hier wurde
versucht die Wahl gezielt zu
beeinflussen das ist eine Schweinerei
meine Damen und Herren
er habe in seiner Jugend Mist gebaut
sagt Aiwanger heute der
antisemitismusbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung kritisiert aiwangers
Umgang mit dem judenfeindlichen Pamphlet
ist mangele an aufklärungswillen
vor allem schadet er ja damit unsere
Erinnerungskultur und den Bemühungen in
Schulen und Gedenkstätten gerade die
junge Generation ein kritischen und
verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit dem Erbe
des Nationalsozialismus beizubringen am
Nachmittag hat Aiwanger angekündigt so
das Fragen noch heute beantworten zu
wollen
wir bleiben noch bei der Union die
Bundestagsfraktion hat ihre Klausur
beendet mit einem Rundumschlag gegen die
ampelregierung gegen
Kindergrundsicherung gegen Heizungs- und
lieferkettengesetz auf der Liste der
Forderungen von CDU und CSU steht unter
anderem Stromsteuer senken und
Sozialabgaben decken die SPD spricht von
einem wünsch dir was Paket Ines Trumps
berichtet
Schmallenberg im Sauerland idyllisch
tiefschwarz Wahlkreis von Friedrich Merz
Treffpunkt der unionsfraktionspitze die
nach Diskussion um Kanzlerkandidat und
den Umgang mit der AFD in die Offensive
kommen will mit Vorschlägen zur
Ankurbelung der Wirtschaft so will die
Union Sozialabgaben auf 40% Deckeln
Überstunden und arbeiten im Rentenalter
steuerfrei machen Unternehmen mit
maximal 25% besteuern Bürokratie abbauen
wir haben noch einmal darauf hingewiesen
dass wir einen Pakt für Leistung
brauchen in Deutschland arbeiten muss
ich wieder mehr lohnen wir brauchen eine
belastungsbremse auch bei den
Sozialabgaben das
wirtschaftschancengesetz der Ampel wird
die Unionsfraktion wohl unterstützen in
der Sozialpolitik aber kritisiert sie
die Steigerung des Bürgergelds bei einem
zeitlich begrenzten Strompreis für die
energieintensive Industrie geht die
Union mit Ziel sei aber den Strompreis
für alle zu senken
die beherzte und umfassende Ausweitung
des energieangebots das wir in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zur Verfügung
hätten wäre der richtige Weg dazu zählt
natürlich auch das wieder hochfahren der
drei stillgelegten Kernkraftwerke rasch
soll der Taurus Marschflugkörper an die
Ukraine geliefert werden es gelte die
Ukraine zu unterstützen und die eigene
Verteidigungsbereitschaft zu steigern
deswegen werben wir dafür dass der
Finanzminister und dass die
ampelregierung den Haushalt der
Verteidigung deutlich steigert nächste
Woche Haushaltsdebatte im Bundestag
erste Möglichkeit für die Union ihre
Vorschläge anzubringen
auch die AFD hat ihre Klausur beendet
angesichts der guten Umfrageergebnisse
trotz die Partei vor Selbstbewusstsein
und entwirft ein eigenes
Regierungsprogramm zurück zu Atomkraft
und Gas aus Russland zählen dazu den
Eckpunkten ebenso wie eine rigide
Flüchtlingspolitik und mehr
Volksabstimmungen Thomas Reichert
informiert
in der Höhen Luft von Oberhof in
Thüringen formuliert die afd-fraktion
einen ebenso luftigen Anspruch
Regierungsübernahme im Bund Aussicht
darauf hat die Partei trotz der Umfragen
derzeit keine trotzdem legt sie ein
zehn-punkte Sofortprogramm vor die
Energiekosten sind deutlich zu hoch aus
dem Grunde würden wir sofort das EEG
kassieren allerdings die EEG-Umlage auf
Strom wurde bereits kassiert von der
Ampel gemeint ist offenbar das Neue
EEG-Gesetz mit dem der Anteil der
Erneuerbaren bis 2030 auf 80% steigen
soll die AFD will Strom stattdessen aus
Atomkraftwerken und Gas aus Russland
über reparierte nordstream-leitungen
trotz Fachkräftemangel würde die AFD
außerdem das Einwanderungsgesetz stoppen
dieses Gesetz werden wir aber sofortig
um ganz schnell rückgängig machen und
ich kann Ihnen sagen nur die AFD hat
diesen Willen dazu diese Einbürgerung
sofortig zu stoppen dabei wird
ziffernexperten den Bedarf an
Zuwanderung für den Arbeitsmarkt auf
400.000 Menschen pro Jahr das DIW in
Berlin kommt zu dem Schluss dass die
afd-politik insbesondere AFD Wähler
Schwert treffen würde unsere Studie
zeigt dass die AFD eine extrem
neoliberale Wirtschafts- und
Finanzpolitik vertritt Sozialleistungen
abbauen will und das sind genau AFD
Wähler und AFD Wähler die unter der
afd-politik viel stärker leiden würden
als andere das treffe insbesondere auch
auf die afd-förderung zu die EU in der
bisherigen Form aufzulösen schließlich
gehen über die Hälfte der deutschen
Exporte in EU-Länder
vor 75 Jahren tagte die Versammlung zum
ersten Mal die unser Grundgesetz
ausgearbeitet hat der Parlamentarische
Rat im naturkundlichen Museum König in
Bonn dem ersten Sitzungsort beging am
Mittag die Staatsspitze des Jubiläum
Bundestagspräsidentin Bass sagte der
Parlamentarische Rat habe leeren gezogen
aus dem dunkelsten Kapitel der deutschen
Geschichte das Grundgesetz habe Pate
gestanden für viele junge Demokratien
weltweit
haben in die Ukraine die USA beobachten
Erfolge des ukrainischen Militärs wir
haben in den vergangenen 72 Stunden
einige bemerkenswerte Fortschritte zur
Kenntnis genommen heißt es aus dem
Nationalen Sicherheitsrat und Präsident
selensky meldet die Ukraine habe eine
Waffe mit großer Reichweite entwickelt
das könnte eine Erklärung sein für
vermehrte Angriffe auf russisches Gebiet
Christian Volk
dieses Video veröffentlicht der
Gouverneur der russischen Region Score
vom kurz nach 23 Uhr die
Luftverteidigung des Militärflughafens
habe ein unbekanntes Objekt abgeschossen
rund 700 km von der ukrainischen Grenze
entfernt eine Anspielung darauf kommt
von Präsident selenski nach einem
Gespräch mit dem Militär es ging um die
Front um die Offensive und um die
Reichweite neuer ukrainischer Waffen sie
beträgt 700 km ziel ist eine noch höhere
Reichweite
offenbar bereits am Mittwoch ziehen von
Drohnenangriffen Satellitenbilder sollen
zerstörte Transportmaschine zeigen seit
Jahresbeginn haben die Angriffe auf
russische Ziele deutlich zugenommen vom
Schwarzen Meer bis nach Nordwest
Russland durch diese Angriffe kann die
Ukraine zeigen dass sie nach wie vor das
Momentum hat die Offensive kommt im
Moment nicht wirklich in die Gänge es
gibt zwar Fortschritte aber trotzdem mit
diesen Angriffen hat man im Prinzip die
Situation dass alle darüber sprechen
dass die Russen offensichtlich nicht in
der Lage sind in der Luft haben zu
sichern und keiner Rede mehr über die
Offensive ein drohnenhersteller in Kiew
kurz nach der Invasion hatten sie hier
acht Mitarbeiter mittlerweile sind es 40
umgerechnet mehrere hundert Millionen
Euro hat die Regierung in diesem Jahr
für Drohnen bereitgestellt in diesem
Betrieb produzieren sie 15 pro Monat die
Mitarbeiter bezeichnen sich selbst als
Soldaten die das eigene Land verteidigen
in der Ukraine war heute Schulanfang
gerade für Erstklässler und ihre
Familien ein ganz besonderer Tag nur
zwingt der Krieg auch hier den Menschen
sein brutales Korsett auf so sollte die
Einschulung in saporicia aus
Sicherheitsgründen online stattfinden
eigentlich wie die Beteiligten damit
umgehen zeigt einer Hebestreit
es ist ein Akt der Anarchie mitten in
saporisia kurz hinter der Front Eltern
und ihre Erstklässler kommen zur
Einschulung obwohl das aus
Sicherheitsgründen strikt verboten ist
[Musik]
und den Kindern einen Feiertag zu
ermöglichen und die neuen Mitschüler
kennenzulernen sind wir auf eigene
Verantwortung und der Einsatz unseres
Lebens in die Schule gekommen
ist mit ihrer zweiten Klasse im
distanzunterricht ins neue Schuljahr
gestartet die Lehrerin unterrichtet vor
lauter Kuscheltieren die Schüler begrüßt
sie auf ihrem Laptop in der Ukraine
beginnt für knapp vier Millionen Kindern
nach den Ferien die Schule wieder mitten
im Krieg landesweit lernt jedes vierte
im distanzunterricht in saporicia alle
Kriegsbeginn gute Erfahrungen mit online
Unterricht gemacht und wir haben auch
viel gelernt auch wie wir mit unseren
Emotionen umgehen müssen
Emotionen die auch aufkommen wenn
draußen plötzlich die Sirenen
Lehrerinnen und Reporter müssen in den
Bunker der Schule zu Hause verlässt Ilja
seinen Rechner und geht mit seiner
Mutter zwitlaner im Flur Entdeckung für
beide ein gut geübtes ritualia würde
aber lieber in der Schule lernen als zu
Hause
in der Schule gehen wir bei luft-
das ist der Schule jetzt aber zu riskant
die mutigen Eltern von saporicia aber
wollten wenigstens die Einschulung ihrer
jüngsten in der Schule feiern
unsere reporterhenner hebe schreibt der
diesen Bericht gemacht hat beantwortet
gleich Ihre Fragen bei ZDF heute live um
19 Uhr in unserer App und auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen
mit dem Herbst steht eine neue
corona-saison bevor und mehr
Atemwegserkrankungen es könne sinnvoll
sein in sensiblen Bereichen wie Klinik
oder Pflegeheim eine Maske zu tragen
empfiehlt heute der
gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
Grünen Damen auch gibt es einen neuen
angepassten corona-impfstoff Impfstoff
ab 18 September wie Experten die Lage
einschätzen zeigt glutenlein aus
Malik Böttcher kennt sich aus mit Corona
der Berliner Hausarzt hat tausende gegen
das kovid-virus geimpft für ihn ist klar
es geht gerade wieder los allerdings
moderat
ist auf jeden Fall dass die
Krankheitslast nicht ansteigen die
Krankheit wäre auch nicht ansteigt die
Patienten zwar sich wieder vermehrt
vorstellen mit positivem Schnelltest
außer Häuslichkeit zum Beispiel und dann
hier PCR bestätigte positive Fälle sind
aber noch nicht schwer Erkrankung seine
Patienten blicken nach inzwischen drei
Jahren Pandemie mit sehr
unterschiedlichen Gefühlen auf das Virus
ich mache mir schon ganz große Sorgen
sozusagen weil ich auch jetzt an
krebserkrankt bin und mein Immunkraft
auch noch geschwächtes also ehrlich
gesagt mache ich mir nicht wirklich
irgendwelche Sorgen oder groß Gedanken
deswegen ich erwarte auch nicht dass es
jetzt genauso wird wie in den letzten
Jahren aber ich könnte mir schon
vorstellen dass wieder vermehrt Masken
getragen werden oder ähnliches
deutschlandweit steigende
Infektionszahlen meldet das
Robert-Koch-Institut mit zuletzt knapp
5000 pro Woche sind es allerdings noch
wenige Fälle ganz normal sagen Experten
angesichts des Gedränges auf Flughäfen
und Rummelplätzen Schafe
corona-maßnahmen wie eine maskenpflicht
sein momentan unnötig
ganz im Gegenteil wir haben ja gesehen
dass wenn wir uns lange mit Masken
schützen dass dann gewisse nachholen
Effekte gegenüber anderen Erregern
auftreten und das gilt es definitiv zu
vermeiden wir sehen zwar formal die
Zahlen ansteigen aber auch extrem
niedrigen Niveau das heißt Besorgnis
wurde noch nicht geäußert und die Lage
ist auch sehr sehr gut im Griff sollten
allerdings Corona Grippe und
schnupfeninfektionen ungünstig
zusammenkommen könnte dies die Kliniken
wieder erheblich belasten
jetzt zu einer spektakulären Betrugs
Geschichte der Hamburger
kupferhersteller und
recycling-spezialist a rubis hat
festgestellt dass in seinen Lagern viel
weniger Edelmetall zu finden ist als in
den Geschäftsbüchern steht der
Fehlbestand ist gewaltig wie das
Unternehmen mitteilte sei bei einer
Überprüfung von angekauften
recyclingprodukten weitaus weniger
Edelmetall festgestellt worden als
gedacht der geschätzte Schaden liegt im
dreistelligen Millionenbereich
Frank Bethmann an der Börse was ist da
passiert naja erst im Juni wurde ja
bekannt dass eine Diebesbande über Jahre
edelmetallhaltige Zwischenprodukte
gestohlen hat damals der Schaden rund 20
Millionen Euro derzeit läuft nun eine
sonderinventur um die Bestände zu
überprüfen und da hat man festgestellt
Mensch wir haben noch ein anderes
Problem unsere Bestände im Lager sind
auch viel weniger wert als in den
Büchern da reden wir jetzt nicht über
Diebstahl sondern eben über betrug
Aurubis verdient sein Geld in dem es
wertvolle Elektronik und anderen Schrott
ankauft und daraus Kupfer Gold Silber
Platin generiert zentral dabei Europa
ist prüft bei der Anlieferung
stichprobenartig wie viel ist der
Schrott Wert und hier können nun
entweder die Stichproben gefälscht
gewesen sein oder um einen
unternehmensprecher zu zitieren man
prüfe auch inwieweit interne Täter
involviert waren also kann es sein dass
eigene Mitarbeiter dem Unternehmen
bewusst geschadet haben nicht
auszuschließen dass sich der Schaden bei
über 100 Millionen Euro bewegt danke
schön für diese Informationen aus
Frankfurt
seit 30 Jahren gibt es die Tafeln doch
die Freude bei der Jubiläumsfeier am
Wochenende dürfte getrübt sein
schließlich sind bis zu 2 Millionen
Bedürftige auf die bundesweit mehr als
960 Tafeln angewiesen diese retten pro
Jahr
265.000 Tonnen Lebensmittel Tendenz
jedoch fallend die Zahl der Bedürftigen
dagegen ist seit dem Ukraine Krieg stark
gestiegen Henriette de Maiziere
liebevoll bereiten Sie alles vor die
Ehrenamtlichen der Berliner Tafel allein
bei der Essensausgabe Leib und Seele
hier in Berlin Spandau bekommen jede
Woche über 500 Menschen Nahrungsmittel
nun die Lebensmittel sind teurer es
bringt mich von Freitag zu Freitag gut
dass es das hier gibt das hilft mir sehr
weil das Geld zum Überleben nicht mehr
reicht die anderen abspritzkosten ob
Wohngeld oder oder
Strompreise oder Mieten sind der alles
teurer geworden die Rente knapp das
Bürgergeld reicht nicht Kranke flüchtet
alleinerziehend die Gründe warum die
Menschen herkommen sind vielfältig
ich mache den Job auch für die Momente
wo die Leute mit Tränen in den Augen
hierher kommen und ich mir dann einfach
mit meiner Kollegin Ablöse und mir Zeit
nehmen für die Leute
Ware zum Verkauf nicht mehr geeignet
aber noch gut verwehrbar allein in
Berlin werden monatlich 660 Tonnen
Lebensmittel verteilt vor 30 Jahren
gründete sich die Berliner Tafel
inzwischen sind Tafeln bundesweit
etablierte Institutionen um Armut am
untersten Ende zu bekämpfen
zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement was
da ansetzt wo staatliche Hilfe nicht
ausreicht angefangen hat die Initiative
Berliner Tafel um Sabine Wert mit
Freunden und einem privaten PKW seither
steigt der Bedarf stetig die Erhöhung
des Bürgergeldes reiche da nicht aus
sagt sie
wir bekommen genau das Resultat des
versagenden
Sozialstaates tagtäglich vorgeführt und
insofern ja die Politik müsste um
einiges mehr tun und ein Satz den
Menschen ausgezahlt wird um 50 € zu
erhöhen das ist eine Klatsche für alle
Armen
Lebensmittel von der Tafel 30 Jahre
Unterstützung 30 Jahre nächsten
die Fernseher werden immer größer die
Kühlschränke schlauer und die neue
Generation smartwatches liefert ihren
Besitzern immer mehr Gesundheitsdaten in
Berlin hat die IFA begonnen die größte
Messe für unterhaltungselektronen und
Haushaltsgeräte in Europa die Branche
hofft trotz der Inflation auf wachsende
Kauflaune bei der Kundschaft Hans-jürgen
Piel hat sich umgesehen
Bildschirme in bisher unerreichter Größe
doch auf der IFA geben jetzt die
Hausgeräte den Takt vor bei der
Ausstellungsfläche haben sie die
Unterhaltungselektronik überholt sind
effizienter und smarter als je zuvor
Beispiel Kühlschränke Vakuum Wände
sorgen für weniger Stromverbrauch Türen
öffnen sich per knopfsignal oder
Sprachbefehl
öfter Backofen der Backofen mit Kamera
erkennt außerdem was sich in ihn
befindet und startet das passende
Programm Sensoren hat auch dieser
Staubsauger an Bord die Unterschiede in
der Boden Beschaffenheit registrieren
und die Saugkraft dann automatisch
anpassen vernetzt und ständig online ist
die neue Haustechnik als Steuerzentrale
mittendrin dient der Fernseher so wollen
es die Hersteller die mit dem
gesammelten Daten auch gutes Geld
verdienen
Daten spielen eine ganz große Rolle
nämlich damit können die Hersteller zum
einen ihre Geräte an die Bedürfnisse der
Nutzer anpassen und Sie können auch
gezielter Werbung schalten nichts Smart
aber mobil dieser tv-koffer mit
integriertem Akku oder der handliche
Videoprojektor für unterwegs Listenpreis
knapp 1000 € im Trend auch 4k Laser
Beamer die dank bild-enzerrung
unmittelbar vor der Projektionsfläche
stehen können doch trotz aller
Innovationen die Branche kämpft mit
Umsatzrückgang wir kommen aus einer
Phase in der Pandemie wo es eine
Sonderkonjunktur für unsere Branchen gab
und letztes Jahr war diese
Sonderkonjunktur irgendwann abgeflacht
da kamen Inflation Krisen dazu weshalb
wir nun eben in einen down hören geraten
sind hohe Erwartungen jetzt an die IFA
die das Geschäft vor Weihnachten wieder
ankurbeln soll
ja und jetzt du Norbert die deutschen
Basketballer jubeln denn ihre
Siegesserie bei der WM in Japan setzt
sich fort ja und obendrein haben Sie
auch schon den Platz im Viertelfinale
sicher vorzeitig dafür waren zwei Dinge
ausschlaggebend der Sieg von Slowenien
gegen Australien und vor allem der
eigene 100 zu 73 Erfolg gegen Georgien
nach mühsamen Auftakt
sie haben die Kurve noch mal bekommen
die bislang so überlegen in deutschen
wackelten zu Beginn ordentlich gegen
Außenseiter Georgien mit wenigen
Aktionen wie diesen rettete das deutsche
Team seinen Vorsprung in die Halbzeit es
gehört auch dazu
so komischen Halbzeiten rauskommen und
es gibt uns eine Möglichkeit besser zu
werden in Halbzeit zwei befreiten sich
die Deutschen mit einem 14:0-lauf
Kapitän deine Schröder hier zum 61 zu 45
und dann gemeinsam mit Daniel Theis in
seinem Element so macht Basketball Spaß
mit 18 Punkten bester Werfer warmer
urolo er traf all seine Dreier und so
zog Deutschland davon gewann mit 100 zu
73 und steht bereits im Viertelfinale
bei Slowenien gegen Australien gewonnen
hat
gestern noch Gold vor Augen am Ende
Platz 4 die deutsche Springreiter Equip
bleibt im Team Wettbewerb der EM in
Mailand ohne Medaille der einzige
Springfehler von Gerrit Nieberg im
letzten ritt mit Ben bedeutet vier
Strafpunkte zu viel für Bronze markus
ening hatte zuvor sein angeschlagenes
Pferd zurückziehen müssen Gold holt
Schweden vor Irland und Österreich
eintracht Frankfurt hat sich für die
UEFA conference League qualifiziert beim
2:0 im Rückspiel gegen Levski Sofia
treffen zwei Neuzugänge zunächst legt
Mario Götze das 1:0 von Ex hertana
Jessica vor der wiederum assistiert
Kurzschluss Elias skiri der zusätzlichen
Raum beginnt aus Köln gekommen ist
um 18 Uhr hat das Transferfenster in der
Bundesliga geschlossen und damit steht
wohl fest Eintracht Frankfurt Stürmer
ist daran der kolonia nie der gestern
den Einsatz verweigerte der wird nicht
zu Paris Saint-Germain wechseln dagegen
hat Union Berlin noch einen populären
Profi verpflichtet Leonardo Bonucci ist
amtierender Europameister mit der
italienischen Nationalmannschaft der
36-Jährige Abwehrspieler kommt von
Juventus Turin und soll die Berliner in
der ersten Champions League Saison
verstärken
bei den US Open hat Alexander Zverev das
deutsche Duell gegen Daniel Altmaier
gewonnen trotz eines satzverlustes gegen
seinen Davis Cup Kollegen sieht der
Hamburger im Hintergrund in vier Sätzen
morgen in der dritten Runde trifft der
Weltrangliste 12 auf den Bulgaren
fliegurt
Beifall für Zverev Schluss mit Sport
Dankeschön zu zweit macht alles mehr
Spaß dachte sich auch der US-Amerikaner
lieben Meier und nahm seinen watussi
Bullen how de du die mit auf eine
Spritztour sonst sind die beiden so eher
auf Paraden unterwegs nach wenigen
Meilen war diesmal
schlussverkehrskontrolle die Beamten
hatten einiges auszusetzen an dem
umgebauten und leicht verschmutzten fort
am Ende gab es aber nur eine Verwarnung
Meyer und haudi dudi durften gemeinsam
nach Hause fahren
das Wochenende bringt den Spätsommer mit
viel Sonne und Wärme und nur wenig Liebe
und Regen Details hat gleich Katja
horneffer das heute journal um 10 mit
Christian Sievers ein schönes Wochenende
wünschen wir Ihnen bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das hier ist das Tief
Günther und seine Warmfront trennte
heute 20 bis 22 Grad im Nordosten von
Werten um die 30 Grad im Süden diese
Warmfront beschäftigt uns auch noch in
der Nacht so fällt noch Regen in
Thüringen und in Sachsen und im Westen
gibt es einige Regenschauer sonst ist es
auch mal klar und das bildet sich Nebel
die Temperaturen sinken auf Werte
zwischen 15 und 8 Grad und morgen sind
die Temperaturen zweigeteilt in
Norddeutschland liegen sie zwischen 21
und 24 Grad im Süden bei 23 bis 30 Grad
das Wetter dazu ist drei geteilt im
Norden wird es freundlich sondern Wolken
wechseln sich ab und auch in
Süddeutschland gibt's zum Teil
strahlenden Sonnenschein in der Mitte
aber halten sich noch die Reste der
waren von heute da fällt noch etwas
Regen und in den westlichen
Mittelgebirgen kann es auch mal Gewitter
geben am Sonntag beschränken sich diese
Gewitter dann hier auf Niederbayern
sonst wird das ein freundlicher Tag bei
Temperaturen von 20 bis 29
Grad und die neue Woche startet sehr
spät sommerlich mit viel Sonnenschein
und Temperaturen von 20 bis 31 Grad
guten Abend